pareil on le sait est la capitale
mondiale du tourisme on vient de le voir
mais autour de paris des petites villes
ont réussi à développer des circuits qui
marche bien
exemple provins seine et marne avec sa
cité médiévale très visitée durant ce
week-end pascal un week-end qui en
général marque le début de la saison
touristique code guérini patrick
d'amiens avant les années 90 prouve à
vivoter sur le moyen-âge
depuis 93 la ville entière fait vivre le
moyen-âge en basse saison comme en haute
saison
rénovation visites individuelles ou
collectives retraités familles toute une
population bon enfant du nord-est du
bassin parisien
on peut comparer maintenant provins un
grand livre ouvert où on peut lire la
vie au moyen âge c'est à dire nous avons
tous les teints la vie militaire la vie
économique
la vie chez aux dalles et tout ça est
concrétisé par des visites guidées des
spectacles des animations des activités
des chouchous sans les jeunes les écoles
les classes qui ont le moyen-âge à leur
programme mais aucun tourisme ne peut se
satisfaire d'une seule clientèle des
étrangers commencent à venir un peu
grâce au parc d'attractions voisin
la coupe du monde n'a pas encore fait
ressentir tous ses effets mais les
étrangers par la force même du site
celle des animations de qualité des
visites guidées
ces étrangers commencent à s'arrêter il
ya des sites importants touristique en
ile-de-france proche de provins donc à
nous de les faire venir aussi approuve
en leur disant il ya des choses
merveilleuses zone de france pas loin de
provins mais provins quelque chose de
très original de très beaux et
authentique et là je crois que pour la
la clientèle étrangère pour les
touristes étrangers
nous avons des atouts majeurs de 70
mille visites annuelles payante il y a
dix ans à 250 milles derrière la preuve
a été faite que pour être efficace une
politique de tourisme local doit être en
synergie avec les autres pôles
il faut du temps de la volonté des
investissements financiers
mais toutes les villes n'ont pas la
chance et les moyens de provins